من ملاعب كره السله العالميه عاد اللاعب
والعرقجي الى ملعب الجامعه التي درس على
مقاعدها في لبنان
لكنه لم يعد كطالب جامعي بل عاد كمتبرع
تكفل بتعليم عدد من الطلاب
مبادره تقديم المنح اقدم عليها طلبه قضى
وجهات مالحه لمساعده الجامعيين ودعم
المؤسسات التي اضطرت لدولاره اقساطها مع
استمرار الازمه الاقتصاديه اجابه ساعدوني
ولدي او بعدهموني وبعتقد بيظلها الاوضاع
الصعبه اللي عم يقطع فيها بلدنا
في الجيل الصاعد الشباب الصاعده وهذا هدفي
ساعد الشباب الصغار اللي عندها حلم يوصلوا
هذه المبيعات التي لجات الى دوله اقساطها
لتحافظ على المستوى الاكاديمي خاصه انها
من اقدم الجامعات في لبنان
لكن القيمين عليها يؤكدون ان نسب الطلاب
الذين يتلقون المساعدات تضاعف حتى وصل الى
السبعين بالمئه وبان نسبه ما يدفعه الطلاب
مقارنه مع الاقساط الماضيه هي بمعدل 35
بالمئه صراحه
يعني حسب الاهل كيف بيقبضوا هيك بس كثير
صعب كيف عم بيعيشوا هلا وخصوصا انه بتعرفي
كيف الدار عم يطلع في كتير مشاكل لكل
التلاميذ
اكيد بزمن حياتنا ما كنا نصرف هالقد على
المنح الدراسيه هالسنه انجبرنا لو ما كان
في مساعدات وما كان في اوقاف بره كنت عده
جامعات سكرت ما فينا نكفي بدون مساعده وما
فينا نكفي على الليره اللبنانيه وما بقى
فينا نكفي على مقدور الطلاب لانه كمان
حالتهم تعبانه
لا تزالوا المؤسسات التربويه تعاني من ثقل
الازمه وهي كغيرها من القطاعات خسرت
العديد من الاساتذه الجامعيين الذين
غادروا لبنان تشكل المساعدات طوق النجاه
لاقدم الجامعات في لبنان بعضها حقق مراكز
متقدمه عالميا لكن الخوف ان تفقد الجامعات
قدرتها على تقديم المساعدات قبل انتهاء
الازمه غنوه يتيم العربيه